Allah.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
In the second of our salah this
evening, we listen to a portion of surah
Al this is the fifth chapter in the
Quran
and this was one of and some scholars
say the last chapter of the Quran to be
revealed to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. It is certainly the last
chapter revealed to him in its subject
matter and that is the finishing touches
on the rulings of Islam and the
intricacies of how to worship Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
This is an incredibly important point
because
the stories that are mentioned in this
chapter are all there to drive that
central theme.
Of course, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions that central theme early on in
the chapter. He says,
"Today I have completed for you all your
religion."
So
this verse was revealed in surah
to the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
during
he stood on the mountain of he gave his
very known and very famous
last farewell hutba and speech there.
And one of the verses that he recited
because that verse had just been
revealed to him was this verse here in
today I have completed and perfected for
you your religion your religion and also
the word dean doesn't just mean religion
but it also means actions and deeds
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala here says
I have fulfilled and completed for you
your religion. I have completed for you
your deeds how you are to conduct
yourselves and I have completed for you
the scales of judgment because all of
these three issues are dealt with in
detail in surah mida.
This chapter is incredibly heavy.
What do I mean by heavy? It is heavy in
its subject matter. It is very grave.
In Muslim Im Ahmed, it was narrated that
when this chapter of the Quran was
revealed to the prophet sallall.aii,
he was riding on his camel alas.
And when Gabriel descended and started
revealing to him this chapter, the
weight of the chapter, a physical weight
was so heavy and strenuous on the camel
that it nearly broke the camel's legs.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam got off of the camel in order
to receive the remainder of the chapter
because it began to buckle under the
weight of this chapter.
One of the stories that are mentioned in
this chapter is the story of Habil and
in English Cain and Abel.
Habil and Kabil are two sons of Adam
and a lot of things are mentioned
things that are taken from the people of
the book and things that are taken from
previous scripture and so forth which
fill in some of the details. However,
when we look just at the text in the
Quran and whatever was authentically
narrated from the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam. We come to a couple of
conclusions about and
number one they were both direct sons to
Adam.
Number two, they were both Muslim. They
were both believers
and yet they were very different in
their attitudes of worship. So Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says to the
prophetam
[Silence]
he says subhanahua to the prophetam
and convey to them tell them the story
the true story
of the two sons of Adam and the incident
that occurred between them when they
both attempted a sacrifice, an offering
to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. This is an
important point. They both attempted an
offering to Allah.
Meaning both of them put forth for
themselves
a in an act of worship
some offering. We don't know from the
Quran what this offering was. It's not
really relevant. In some narrations it's
mentioned not narrations of the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam. But
in some narrations of the companions and
it's mentioned that
was a farmer and Habil was a herder. He
had sheep. He was a shepherd. And so
Kabil
put forth from the yield of his harvest
the lowest thing that he had to offer
from his harvest.
He collected from his harvest as we know
fruits and you know vegetables and
whatever it is that a person harvests.
There's really nice fruits, there's
medium and then there's the lowest the
bottom of the barrel as they say.
He offered to Allah the lowest thing
that he had. Why did he do that? There's
a number of reasons, but it boils down
to
he is more focused on the dunya than he
is on the hereafter.
That's the bottom line. Why?
Because all of this harvest, the very
nice fruits, the medium fruits, the
lowest fruits, they represent dollar
signs. They cost different things. And
so he took what he couldn't sell and he
gave that to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
because he didn't want to miss out on
whatever the dunya had to offer him with
regards to the best of what he had and
what his crops yielded. Habin was very
different. He was a stark opposite.
Habib took the best of his herd and put
that forward as an offering and a
sacrifice to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Now notice two Muslims
worshiping Allah with the same act of
worship
yet very different intentions
and very different acts.
Here is the question. This is one of the
things that plagues us as Muslims. A
misunderstanding.
What is the misunderstanding?
The misunderstanding is
well, you know, as long as I hit the
bare minimum threshold,
then I'll be okay.
What does that mean? for making
salah, as long as I make five prayers
and I barely make enough for it to be
acceptable by Allah, technically
acceptable to where you couldn't say I
didn't pray. I did pray,
but the prayer was haphazard and it was
the bare bare bare minimum.
Then Jenna is the what is the eventual
abode.
Maybe I'll have to go to hell for a
little bit. Maybe maybe I'll be punished
by Allah for a little bit, but in the
long run I'll be able to go to Jenna.
And I want anything from Jenna just as
long as I get into Jenna eventually.
If I make it into the lowest lowest
lowest levels of paradise, then it's all
good. And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us in the Quran that he'll remove
jealousy and envy from our hearts when
we enter paradise. That the lowest level
of paradise is seven times better than
anything on earth. It's good enough for
me. Right? This is the idea that drives
this attitude and this result.
This is what drives him. You can't
technically say I didn't do my my do my
service. I fulfilled my service. I gave
I made an offering to Allah. Sure it was
the lowest and sure but I did it. You
can't say I didn't do it. Then you have
a stark contrast to that. His brother
Habian,
he takes the best that he has
and he makes that is his offering.
He's paying very close attention to
what? To the details.
Because the details matter.
Imagine if you were going to buy a car.
Do you not care if there's a scratch
here or scratch there? Missing bolt
here, missing bolt there? There's a flat
tire in the back. Is there a spare?
Yeah, there's a Don't. Okay, good
enough. Would you put your Would you buy
that car with your hard-earned money?
If you want to go buy something that
you're going to ride in every day or a
house, is it okay if there's a little
bit of water damage here and there? Not
to fix it up in the future. I'm speaking
about this is what you're buying. This
is what you're going to live in. This is
what you're going to drive in. Little
some termites underneath the the the
floorboards. It's not that bad. It's not
that big of an infestation, right? It's
good enough. Is there a roof?
Technically, it has a roof, right?
Technically, it has walls. Technically,
it's a house. You can't say it's not a
house. Is that how we go about in our
lives?
Especially with things that matter to us
when we go to get married. Is this
really how we look at the person that's
our potential spouse?
She's, you know, missing an eye or she
has very terrible
stench odor, right? But she's a woman.
You can't say she's not a woman, right?
He's a man, you know, he's broke. He has
no education.
You can't say he's not a man. This is
not how we live our lives because these
things matter to us. We know that we're
going to end up living there. If you
understand that about the hereafter,
you understand that everything you're
doing right now, me, myself, this
moment, everything that I've done in the
in my past, my whole life, and
everything else that will come out of my
mouth, every action I make, everything I
believe, everything I do and I don't do,
that is all me preparing my grave.
That's all that is.
Every time I speak, I'm making an
adjustment to my grave. I'm either I'm
either turning up the temperature in my
grave or I am planting another garden.
Those are those are the two things I'm
doing. Every time I speak, every time I
do something, every time I stand to
pray, I am either turning up the
temperature, making my grave smaller,
making it more inhospitable,
making it smell more foul, or I am doing
the opposite. I am making my grave just
a bit bigger.
I am making it just a bit more soothing.
I am making it just a bit more
comfortable.
If you know this, this is what our
prophet taught us sallall.aii wasallam.
Not only if you know this, but if you
believe it with every fiber of your
being, you allow yourself to believe it.
You don't second guess it. You honestly
believe it.
Just you are speaking, as real as
this world is, that is where I'm going
to lay. If we have that,
then our actions will be very different.
We wouldn't just come to pray. I mean,
imagine today if every time you come to
pray or stand to pray, you are paid
based on you're paid money based on your
performance in that prayer.
How you dress, how focused you are, how
close to the sunnah it was. Is your
prayer the prophet's prayer? How
are the pillars? How are the sunnah? How
are the wedge you bet? And every mistake
you make or everything that you are
unaware of because you didn't take the
time to study it and learn it, you lose
money. How would our prayers be? Would
they change? Would they be better? Would
they get better over time? Would we
perfect them? This is really what it is.
It's no different than that. The only
thing is our reward is just a little bit
delayed.
Subhanah!
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.